he said once that your motivation to be
in to be a successful person in life
yeah came from the Spice Girls
it's did my yeah my when I was growing
up I my kind of core group of friends
were all girls III had kind of you know
male friends at school but it was mainly
girls that I hung around with at home
and that was in 97-98 when the Spice
Girls were just ginormous and so I
thought well if I try and get into the
Spice Girls then I'm gonna be accepted
in this group I didn't have to try for
very long this is the struggle really
eased off before long and I was into it
more than anybody else and I know you
became a fan for real you really did
real fight and I and I loved Geri
Halliwell
ginger spice like I loved isn't even
like too strong the word and so it's all
I think but it just seemed so far away
from where I was when I was a kid and I
was like how can i meet Geri Halliwell
exactly I'm about 10 years old
how could I meet her it seemed
impossible I thought well I'm gonna have
to become famous as well I guess and I
thought well I should become an actor
because that's the only way that I can
get to Mia and that's the inspiration
for my entire career
obvious question have you met her no
because I'm here the father the fact I'm
here you make it sound like you were
about to meet her when the call came to
do phone it gotta go I'm here and the
fact that I'm still active in the IC yes
I'm still active means I haven't which
the second I Mia I'm done yeah
I'm retired you can't meet her you can
never meet her now if if I'd have met
her like in season after season for a
game of Thrones open like nothing not my
problem the only character that killed
themselves
[Laughter]